with us in Rhode Island I am me welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank you I'm
excited to talk to you
you too how can I help I have a son
who's 18 years old he is a classical
musician he plays symphonic tuba he is
he has a gift he has a passion and he
puts forth extraordinary effort he is at
a private music school he's a freshman
while the private music schools are
about seventy thousand dollars he
received twenty five thousand dollars in
scholarships for each of the four years
he'll be going to this school
unfortunately that doesn't cover it
he took out a 38 thousand dollar loan
which is scary but I don't know how to
encourage him going forward I don't see
how he can do that for four years then
the kicker is my parents are everyday
millionaires and they keep telling me to
let them take out the loans because
eventually I will inherit money and be
able to help him pay them off so I don't
know it doesn't sound like a good idea
but I don't see how he's going to be
able to slow down a second okay I said
seventy thousand dollars a year that's
with room and board yes okay and so for
four years we're gonna have two hundred
and eighty thousand dollars invested to
be a gifted tuba player I know I don't
see I mean that we're we're do you may I
don't know enough about the music world
the only thing I can think of as an
orchestra position I don't know any
soloist tubas that have ever sold
millions of records off the top of my
head as a consumer I don't know of that
and so he would like to play in a
symphony orchestra he will know that
make money like he'll make like forty
thousand dollars a year unless he's in
the Boston Philharmonic or something
even then but I don't understand that he
can't get the training he needs at a
private school item excuse me at a
public school my point is though that
the trainings not worth it
so
what do I tell him to change dreams I
would live my dream a different way
because this dream is quickly becoming
what's known as a nightmare yeah you're
gonna have a guy making $35,000 a year
that has spent two hundred and eighty
thousand dollars and two hundred
thousand dollars in debt
waiting on his grandparents to die to
get him out of this which sounds
terrible it is awful
it's a horrible use of your family's
legacy in your own family's money
and it's not to say that the young man
doesn't isn't gifted I'm not I'm not
putting down tuba players and I'm not
putting down his gift I'm just trying to
be wise in loving my son well and not
assure him into a bear trap that tears
his leg off yeah and all in the name of
a dream right because he's gifted and I
don't doubt that he's gifted but me and
him if he's mine we're about to have a
come-to-jesus meeting and that's gonna
sound like I love you so much I will not
participate in things that harm you okay
and you we need to take I'll help you
I'll coach you I'm your biggest
cheerleader
I'm your biggest fan of your giftedness
and of your musical ability and your
instrument of choice I'm your biggest
fan I'm your mom nobody loves you more
than that and it's like with federal law
were required to love you even when
you're dumb and you're not being dumb
you're brilliant but I want to walk with
you and help you and honey what we're
doing here together and I'm standing on
the sidelines watching a car wreck with
my son in the car I don't want to
participate in this I don't want you to
do this I want to find some other way
for you to live out your giftings with
and your passions in the music world and
in a way that becomes that doesn't trap
you can you imagine who he's gonna be
when he's 42 and your parents are still
alive yeah yeah that's right the 42 year
old version of him is gonna hate you
guys
yeah we're not stopping this train wreck
that was a beautiful way now that I have
presenting this and that's what I called
for us because I knew the answer but
thank you for helping me put it into
words for him well it's all it's all
about helpings it's all about loving
somebody's not just thrashing them right
but and if there and if he knows
something that I don't know or you know
something I don't know I'm willing to
learn I just as a sitting outside the
music business I'm in talk radio for
reason I can't even carry it to him I
don't even know anything about it so but
I mean I I've observed the music
business in Nashville for years and I
know what the percentages are of making
a living much less making it big and
that's with people that play instruments
and genres of music that are more
widespread through the public and
actually monetize right but even then I
mean the joke around Nashville's how do
you get the next country music stars
attention waiter yeah you know they're
all everybody in this town can play in
yodel you know yeah and and yet a whole
bunch of them never get to the number of
people that were on American Idol that
now work on my team is blow your mind
you know and so it's just it's a very
difficult world to the show business
world to start with and then you take a
nuanced slice of that a small slice of
that and I fear for this young man's
future and I and I'm like you I love him
I want him to do good hey thanks for the
call you know that's a really good
discussion right there y'all and that
mom is if she follows through on this as
being a great mom and it's gonna be
awkward it's gonna be hard but the times
that I've been a great dad they were
awkward at times the times that I've
been a great Papa Dave grandpa yeah
those are awkward yeah we got get ready
to be number six six and under the
grandbabies you don't think they don't
have some interesting discussions with
Papa Dave and they're running around
screaming in my house like a bunch of
pterodactyls you know it's like hey man
are you raised go outside if you're
gonna you know so um but you know you
just it's part of parenting it's part of
grandparenting it's part of good
relationships is being kind enough to
have the courage to say
out loud that everyone else is thinking
and so if your child has a path that is
their dream but it's going to lead them
into a financial nightmare then it's
really not a dream it's it's a series of
bad decisions as what it is and you've
got to look at that I mean I'm not
against people having a music degree I'm
not against people having an art degree
I'm not against your having a degree in
sociology but don't spend two hundred
fifty thousand dollars for a master's
degree in sociology so you can work for
the state making 38 grand as a case
worker that's dumber than a rock don't
do that because you have a big heart and
you care for broken families and
children that are struggling I got a big
heart I care for broken families and for
children that are struggling I want you
to be able to help them but a $250,000
investment for a $38,000 job this is
known as DOM and this is where people
have said all we have to quit you know
college education is no longer worth it
yeah a college education is worth is
worth every dime you pay for it at an
inexpensive good solid state school in a
field of study that will ROI I was in
school we had a field of study called
logistics they now call it supply chain
and come out with a four-year degree in
supply chain from the University of
Tennessee I talked to a kid young man
that graduated two years ago from the
University of Tennessee with a degree in
supply chain paid twelve thousand
dollars a year in tuition to go his job
coming out of college was 83,000 his
first job and he'll be making 120 in 30
minutes in that field
I mean his the career track is straight
up now that's what's known as a return
on investment that's education that has
a great marketplace value and this is
what we coach people and if we're smart
moms and dads and grandparents and
grandparents if you're every day
millionaires don't tell your kids to go
to something stupid and when you die
they can use the money to pay it off oh
my gosh
it's like you know I'll pay for your
drug rehab after I'm gone ah
I just don't that's not a loving act
well sweet lady what's sweet lady a
great call